for the first time in recent years the
US has turned down an extradition
request from the UK and cyclists fled
Britain after allegedly hitting and
killing 19 year-old Harry Dunne with her
car the State Department says she had
diplomatic immunity
MTS tyub is outside the US Embassy in
London MTS what's the British response
to this good morning well Harry Dunn's
family certainly not very happy about
this decision by secretary Pompeo but
they remain defiant and continue to have
high-level support in a statement from
the UK Foreign Secretary Dominic Raab he
said quote that he's urgently
considering other options and also went
on to say that Britain would have acted
differently in a similar case now we of
course have been following the case of
Harry Dunne very closely from the very
beginning we spoke with his mother
Charlotte Charles
earlier this morning here's what she
told us nothing's gonna make us go away
and it doesn't matter how long it takes
if it means that we've got to wait until
the next administration and four and a
half five years time then we will know
you'll remember Harry Dunn's parents met
President Trump in the Oval Office last
year where they sensationally had an
cyclists waiting in another room at the
White House now the family turned that
meeting down and since then Britain's
courts have charged soukous
with dangerous driving causing death if
convicted the American mother of three
could face up to 14 years in prison
something that Harry Dunn's family say
could have been entirely avoided had she
not fled the country Gale we remember
when the Harry Dunn's parents were here
at this table very very sad story Thank
You MTS reporting from London